will smith just had an episode of david
letterman's new show come out will
smith's episode was taped before
the slap heard around the world before
the oscars when he went up and smacked
chris rock for telling a completely
innocuous joke about will smith's wife
in this interview with david letterman
will smith describes this premonition of
possibly losing his career possibly
losing everything and he got this
premonition
because he had what what he is
describing as a kind of religious
experience but it wasn't an ordinary
religious experience it was because he
was high on the drug ayahuasca
stop drinking i'm sitting there and then
all of a sudden it's like i start seeing
all of my money flying away and my house
is flying away and my career has gone
away and i'm like ah all right i'm
trying to like grab for my money and my
career my whole life is getting
destroyed so this is your fear this is
my fear and i'm in there but i'm in
there and i'm wanting to vomit and all
of that and i hear a voice saying this
is what the [ __ ] it is
this is what the life is and i'm going
oh [ __ ] and i hear willow screaming
daddy help me daddy how come you won't
help me and i'm like i don't see you
baby i don't see you and shauna's like
relax relax relax and she totally sit up
she tells me sit up and then slowly i
was like like i stopped caring about my
money i just want to get to willow stop
caring about my house i stopped caring
about my career and
i get to the point where
i settle down and the voice is still at
100
i still hear willow screaming my money
is still flying away but i'm going
and i'm totally calm even though there's
hell going on in my mind when i came out
of it i realized that anything that
happens in my life i can handle it i can
handle
any person i lose
i can handle
anything that goes wrong in my life i
can handle anything in my marriage i can
handle anything that this life has to
offer me
that's part of the psychological
training that happens in ayahuasca if
that's what the psychological training
of ayahuasca is promising will smith
i think he should ask for a refund
because it didn't work did it because
not only can will smith
quite evidently not handle anything that
comes in his marriage or his
professional life or anything else he
can't handle an innocent joke from a
comedian
about his family during an awards show
about his wife about his actress wife
his public figure wife he can't even
handle that without losing his mind and
i don't mean just to beat up on will
smith
this is what happens when people
do a lot of drugs and do lots of crazy
uh behaviors and engage in that kind of
stuff things go bad i have so many
friends who have gotten into
psychedelics and they really love
psychedelics they've tried to get me to
do them i've never been interested
because i don't want to break my brain
you know i'm not the brawniest guy so if
my brain breaks then i'm kind of screwed
you know and i said no no i i don't
think i want that they said no man you
get these really spiritual experiences i
said i know i go to church so i get i
get plenty of spiritual experiences i
really and i know that those are not
coming from some chemical that's
breaking down my brain matter but uh
from something a little bit higher i
would like to think so no thanks no
thanks i don't i don't want the drugs
and every person i know every single one
who has gotten into psychedelics
has ended up worse for it
every person i know who's really gotten
into the psychedelic stuff
has ended up the worse because they have
done it and they all think they're
better they all think they've seen
something but they haven't
or maybe they have seen things but i
don't think they're seeing good things
i don't you know when that voice is
screaming this is what the if it is i
don't i don't think that's an angel
yelling at you if it's not just a
hallucination i'm not sure it's an angel
that's yelling at you daddy daddy where
are you sorry honey i can't find you i'm
super high on drugs i'm tripping out of
my mind right now so i can't find you
honey this is not
the thing that responsible people do
this is not the way
to find some meaning in your life
people are drawn to this because it gets
us right back to what we were talking
about at the top of the show
people are drawn to
psychedelics
and
even extreme diets
and even a really extreme kind of
uh
physical exercise like yoga for they're
drawn to yoga not just because they like
to stretch
but because they want meaning
they're drawn to yoga because yoga is
actually a religious liturgy it's a
religious ritual they're drawn even
something as plain as a as an extreme
diet very often they're they're they're
drawn to that because it's more natural
it's more in tune with the earth the way
we're supposed to be the things we ought
to do and they're especially drawn to
drugs for this reason
and most especially the hallucinogenics
the psychedelics because they think that
they have a religious longing
that's totally normal that's totally
natural man is a religious being
but you're not gonna you're not gonna
get the right answers that way
you are not going to fill that gaping
hole in your heart that you're longing
for with all that stuff
you're not gonna some people try to fill
it with politics and they turn politics
into their their greatest ultimate
crusade
you're not going to fill it with
politics either i'm not saying get out
of the political realm
but you you don't want to put the cart
before the horse which is what which is
what pelosi is doing which is what all
these guys are doing
they're saying i
my
chief
object of worship is my own will is my
own desire it's what i want and
ideally that goes along with religion
and custom and culture and all this
stuff but if it doesn't damn it if i've
got to choose between my own will and
my faith what i say is my faith my will
is going to win and i'm going to make my
faith bend toward my will
me me me what i want what i want to do
me me me all the time that's what it is
that's what it comes down to
which is not
just not a good thing i'm glad you like
that clip now hold up don't go you gotta
smash and ring and click and jab and
poke and any way you gotta subscribe and
that way you'll get the notifications
also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review leave a 10 star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you